elon musk is the richest person in the
world and he has a wild theory as to who
satoshi nakamoto the founder and creator
of bitcoin is now remember elon he
started a bunch of really great
companies everything from tesla to
spacex the boring company neural link
and many many others he's obviously got
more money than anyone else in the world
quite literally and he was the time
person of the year last year now elon
recently tweeted what everyone thought
was a meme but maybe elon actually
thinks this is exactly who satoshi
nakamoto is he went ahead and he showed
samsung toshiba nakamichi and motorola
if you take the first letters from each
of these words it literally spells
satoshi nakamoto could it be that these
large four technology companies are
actually behind the creation of bitcoin
i don't think so and i doubt that elon
actually believes that but back a couple
of years ago elon was asked who did he
think that satoshi nakamoto was and his
answer was nick zabo nixabo is famous
for coining the term smart contract he
was very involved in cryptography and
the cypherpunk movement and in all sorts
of things around the creation and the
testing of digital currencies nick zabo
has gone ahead and denied that he's
actually satoshi nakamoto but elon musk
the richest person in the world maybe he
thinks that it's the four technology
companies maybe he thinks it's nick zabo
but now that tesla holds bitcoin on
their balance sheet and the richest man
in the world says that a material
portion of his net worth is in bitcoin
he's probably thinking a lot about who
the hell is satoshi nakamoto hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time